so you're a mother at this point and
you're taking all these classes and
extracurricular she's seeing something
she's like seeing this love this passion
for it yeah she knew but she you know
then that you know you're going
somewhere
you know when i eventually a year later
got offered this tv show in california
and basically i had to leave my whole
life to go do that what was that it was
called the amanda show with amanda bynes
amanda how is she to work she's the
greatest was she really the greatest
again much like going to this performing
arts high school i show up and it's a
sketch comedy show
and she's she's like the carol burnett
and
i and of course they ice me right away
which i don't blame them for but i had
been sort of put i had been highly
suggested that i get this job from the
president of nickelodeon who had met me
a year before and was like you got
something you're funny
and
as you know producers love being told
what to do right and they were like okay
and they took me but they didn't know so
i was relegated to
waiter number three in sketchup oh boy
but instead of being resentful i was
like embraced it yeah and i just watched
her cause i'm like we're six months
apart in age but you are like decades
ahead of me inability and i just sort of
studied her instead of being pissed i
was on the bench did she like you
i think or did she not really was aware
of you she wasn't aware of you as much
as like i don't well you were the third
waiter this the server yeah i remember
yeah you had you have something yeah you
like the snack table
you still like the snack table at that
point oh that's when i really started
doing damage i'm like this is free
you